freunde der sonne was ist hier gerade
schon wieder los die ganze kita
schuldebatte ging ja eigentlich schon
rund als am 19 mai eine gemeinsame
stellungnahme mehrerer medizinischer
fachgesellschaften rauskamen mit der
überschrift schulen und kitas sollen
wieder geöffnet werden der schutz von
lehrern erziehern betreuern und eltern
und die allgemeinen hygieneregeln stehen
dem nicht entgegen was war ja in der
welt der wissenschaftlichen
stellungnahmen schon mal ein fetter drop
das glaube ich der korrekte fachbegriff
aber jetzt ist es einfach eskaliert ihr
habt es doch bestimmt mitbekommen
diese ganze sache her schulen und kitas
sind ja ohnehin eines der schwierigsten
krone themen und eines der wichtigsten
und dringendsten und man könnte jetzt
die ganze aufregung positiv sehen weil
sie wenigstens mal ein bisschen wind in
die sache bringt aber diese art von wind
können wir gerade gar nicht gebrauchen
es wohl durch ein t hole durch viel tee
müssen uns allem ein bisschen entspannen
deswegen schauen wir uns mal die ganze
kita schuldebatte ganz sachlich und
unaufgeregt an deswegen macht es euch
gemütlich erstmal an alle drama queens
keine sorge wir werden hier natürlich
die kosten studie auch behandeln aber
lasst nicht vergessen um was es hier
eigentlich geht es geht hier um die
kitas kindergärten und schulen und ob
sie wieder geöffnet werden sollen und
ich befürchte dass wir gerade vor lauter
drama um ein puzzleteil den blick aufs
ganze vergessen kann gehen mit der
stellungnahme an unterschrieben wurde
diese stellungnahme von der deutschen
gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene in
der deutschen gesellschaft für
pädiatrische infektiologie der deutschen
akademie für kinder- und jugendmedizin
der gesellschaft für hygiene
umweltmedizin und präventivmedizin und
dem berufsverband der kinder und
jugendärzte
und das ist was denn im gegensatz zu
einer wissenschaftlichen studie drückt
eine stellungnahme einen konsens auf dem
man sich geeinigt hat und dieser hier
klingt ja anders als das was wir bisher
von epidemiologen oder virologe gehört
haben das ging ja eher in die richtung
[Musik]
ja
neben der epidemiologe und virologen
brille ist eben auch diese mediziner und
hygieniker sicht relevant für politische
entscheidungsträger und die haben es ja
gerade nicht einfach die krux mit den
kitas und schulen schulen kindergärten
kitas zu schließen richtet große
kollateralschäden an auf verschiedenen
ebenen die bildung fällt aus und soziale
unterschiede verschärfen sich die kinder
können nicht mehr richtig zu hause
betreut werden
das fängt bei vernachlässigung an und
geht bis zu gewalt und missbrauch und
auch viele eltern gehen kaputt durch die
doppelbelastung von arbeit und beruf
gleichzeitig ist die öffnung natürlich
riskant weil die kinder sich nicht nur
gegenseitig anstecken können sondern
natürlich auch erzieher lehrer eltern
großeltern
also da bin ich nur froh keine
politikerin zu sein die das jetzt
entscheiden muss wenn ich das persönlich
verantworten müsste würde ich mir nicht
hose machen
mehrmals aber diese medizinischen
fachgesellschaften haben den mut klare
ansagen auf den tisch zu legen und zwar
bitte öffnen wobei das ja noch lange
nicht die ganze geschichte ist was die
verarbeitung in den medien anbelangen in
den ersten medien erschrecken das ist dr
peter walde infektiologe arzt für innere
und intensiv medizin und er ist autor
der stellungnahme
wir hatten den eindruck es wird nur die
überschrift zitiert und wir hatten
deshalb auch in den sozialen medien auf
diese erste reaktion aber da muss ich
auch leider öffentlich rechtliche
anstalten mit nennen spiegel mit nennen
die einfach in der überschrift sagen
hier wollen experten die kritiklose
uneingeschränkte öffnung also nehmen wir
uns doch mal die zeit wie gesagt dass
die schäden der schul und kita
schließungen riesig sind das wissen wir
wie groß ist das risiko einer öffnung
ist das ist jetzt halt die entscheidende
frage und jetzt endlich lässt sich diese
frage aufteilen auf drei fragen erstens
sind kinder selbst
denn er gefährdet 2 stecken sich kinder
seltener an
drittens sind kinder weniger ansteckend
gehen wir mal alle drei fragen durch
erstens sind kinder seltener gefährdet
ja das hat sich schon früh abgezeichnet
und die hinweise haben sich seither auch
nur verdichtet also kinder haben trotz
infektion oft keine oder nur milde
symptome kinder ein bisschen selten ins
krankenhaus und haben seltener schwere
verläufe und sie versterben seltener
sie besteht also aktuell ein
wissenschaftlicher konsens auch wenn
durch die medien ab und zu ein anderer
eindruck entsteht wenn gross über
einzelne schicksale berichtet wird aber
wie so oft mit nachrichten wenn etwas
seltenes passiert dann erregt es
natürlich viel aufmerksamkeit aber diese
aufmerksamkeit ist ja nicht statistisch
korrekt verteilt ihr wisst was ich meine
also hier können wir derzeit
zuversichtlich mit ja antworten zweitens
stecken sich kinder seltener an
bei dieser frage ist die datenlage
leider nicht mehr so eindeutig es gibt
da einige interessante studien aus der
ganzen welt die in der stellungnahme
zitiert werden die werden hier jeweils
kurz zusammengefasst ich habe mir die
zitierten studien im originaltext
angeschaut und dabei ist mir aufgefallen
dass hier und da ein paar wichtige
aspekte fehlen die in dieser
zusammenfassung nicht auftauchen ich
gehe hier jetzt mal nur auf einen aspekt
ein um exemplarisch zu zeigen warum es
in dieser frage noch unsicherheiten gibt
zum beispiel wird hier der whu china
joint mission report genannt in dem
steht dass kinder unter 18 jahren
scheinbar eine relativ geringe
ansteckungsrate haben also scheinbar
achtet auf den wortlaut setzt und das am
anfang der epidemie in haan lange gar
keine positiven unter 18-jährigen
getestet wurden
das klingt ja jetzt erst mal gut
allerdings gibt es hier ein problem das
haben wir auch gerade schon genannt
nämlich kinder haben oft keine oder nur
milde symptome und das allein führt ja
schon dazu dass kinder seltener getestet
werden genau dieses auswertungs problem
ist in der originalquelle auch angemerkt
also man müsste eigentlich großflächig
serologische tests auf antikörper
durchführen um herauszufinden wer hat
die krankheit bereits durchgemacht dann
wird man nämlich auch diejenigen
erfassen deren infektion mann
bilder symptome nicht bemerkt hatte also
stichwort dunkelziffer und diese
dunkelziffer könnte gerade bei kindern
besonders hoch sein
deswegen steht hier ausdrücklich dass
man eben noch nicht sagen kann ob sich
kinder tatsächlich seltener anstecken
und übrigens auch nicht ob sie weniger
ansteckend sind oder hier wird
hingewiesen auf den aktuellen server der
deutschen gesellschaft für pädiatrische
infektiologie die seit dem 18
märz die daten aller kinder erhebt die
weko wird 19 im krankenhaus behandelt
werden müssen
und selbst in kliniken von hotspots wo
es größere ausbrüche gab wurden bisher
nur vereinzelt kinder hospitalisiert
okay aber auch hier dasselbe problem
denn wir wissen ja dass kinder seltener
schwere verläufe haben und selten ins
krankenhaus müssen deswegen ist eine
geringe hospitalisierung rate allein
noch kein ausreichender hinweis für die
frage stecken sie sich auch seltener an
ganz ähnliche probleme haben wir bei der
frage sind kinder weniger ansteckend
paar sachen kann man sich dazu überlegen
also wenn kinder seltener symptome haben
dann husten sie auch seltener und
könnten allein deswegen weniger
ansteckend sein dann kann man sich
fragen ob das vielleicht kompensiert
wird dadurch dass kinder in der kita
natürlich viel intensiveren
körperkontakt haben als erwachsene im
büro das sind alles plausible
überlegungen aber halt bisher noch nicht
systematisch untersucht in der
stellungnahme werden hinweise aus
verschiedenen ländern zusammengetragen
dass infektionen ist er hauptsächlich
von erwachsenen ausgingen und nicht von
kindern und das wird interpretiert als
hinweis darauf dass kinder weniger
ansteckend sind zum beispiel beim server
der dgb zeigt sich dass die infektionen
bei stationär behandelten kindern in 81
prozent über die eltern erfolgte also
nicht durch andere kinder doch in diesem
beispiel aus deutschland muss man
beachten dass die daten seit dem 18 märz
erhoben werden das bedeutet wir
beobachten gerade eine situation in der
schule und kitas ohnehin weitestgehend
geschlossen sind
und es sind vor allem die erwachsenen
die das haus verlassen zum beispiel für
die arbeit kontakt haben infektion nach
hause bringen insofern ist es nur
erwartbar dass die infektionen bisher
hauptsächlich von erwachsenen ausgehen
so lange kitas und schulen geschlossen
sind kann man natürlich nicht beobachten
wie sich kinder jetzt genau in kitas und
schulen anstecken und hier kommt jetzt
die besagte studie von boston steam ins
spiel die versucht hat das ganze
indirekt zu untersuchen
und da das ganze dank bild völlig aus
dem ruder gelaufen ist machen wir dafür
jetzt mal ein extra kapitel die
bedeutung von postens studie
eigentlich wollte ich gar nicht so viel
zeit mit dieser studie verbringen weil
sie nur ein puzzleteil von vielen ist
aber ich muss jetzt diesen exkurs machen
weil dank bild gerade die prinzipien
wissenschaftliche arbeit katastrophal
missverstanden werden
drosten steam hat sich gefragt wie hoch
ist denn die viruslast bei kindern also
wieviel virus haben infizierte kinder im
rachen mit dem sie dann andere anstecken
können könnten nicht können also die
viruslast ist nur ein indirekter hinweis
auf die infektiosität von kindern bei
anderen krankheiten weiß man also zb
erkältungsviren dass kinder wichtige
lehren schleudern sind also die haben
eine viel höhere virus konzentration als
erwachsene
aber vielleicht haben kinder alko witt
19 ja weniger virus im rachen das könnte
nicht nur erklären warum sie sehr sehr
schwer betroffen sind sondern könnte
auch heißen dass sie weniger ansteckend
sind genau das wollte tossens team
überprüfen und fand keinen hinweis
darauf dass kinder eine geringere
viruslast haben als erwachsene
ihr fazit kinder könnten genauso
infektiös sein wie erwachsene gab es
aber inhaltliche kritik von anderen
wissenschaftlern also zumindest das hat
sich die bild nicht ausgedacht also es
gab statistiker mathematiker die die
statistischen methoden der studie
kritisieren um die statistik
nachzuvollziehen müsste ich ein extra
video machen aber ich will jetzt hier
auf
eine sache eingehend damit ihr euch so
eine ungefähre vorstellung davon machen
könnt auf welchem level die experten
hier diskutieren
man könnte jetzt vielleicht denken wo
ist eigentlich das große problem ich
habe hier verschiedene rachenabstrich
proben von kindern von erwachsenen von
verschiedenen altersgruppen ich dann
doch jetzt einfach schauen ob bei den
kindern weniger virus drin ist oder
nicht dann habe ich mein ergebnis ganz
so einfach ist es leider nichts also
letztendlich werdet ihr ja immer ein
unterschied finden es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass jetzt auf die
kommastelle genau denselben
durchschnittswert in der viruslast bei
kindern und erwachsenen findet die frage
ist ja ist dieser unterschied nur
zufällig oder ist er statistisch
signifikant was so viel heißt wie nicht
durch zufall erklärbar und hier gibt es
so genannte statistische tests die man
mit seinen daten machen kann die einem
dann eben sagen dieser unterschied ist
statistisch signifikant oder eben nur
zufall so und abgekürzt gesagt hat
'jetzt ostens team in ihren auswertungen
keinen statistisch signifikanten
unterschied gefunden zwischen der
viruslast von kindern und erwachsenen
jetzt gibt es aber ein paar statistik
also deren täglich brot ist es solche
statistischen auswertungen zu machen und
die sagen jetzt diese statistischen
tests die jetzt hier in der studie
gemacht wollen sie sind nicht geeignet
so man hätte das anders aus werden
sollen zwei unabhängige wissenschaftler
haben also ich vereinfache jetzt wieder
die daten der posten studie neu und
anders ausgewertet und fanden dann doch
statistisch signifikante unterschiede
um dieses open review ging eigentlich
noch weiter und sagt selbst in tossens
eigene auswertung kommt doch bereits ein
statistisch signifikanter unterschied
zwischen kindergarten kindern und
menschen über 45 raus bisher hat
christian drosten im ndr podcast gesagt
dass er einen seiner kritiker mit ins
team geholt hat und dass sie das
gemeinsam überarbeiten aber bevor diese
überarbeitung jetzt nicht veröffentlicht
ist finde ich ziemlich müßig darüber zu
spekulieren zumal auch die rohdaten noch
nicht veröffentlicht sind zumindest
jetzt nicht jetzt wo ich das sie
aufnehmen kann sein dass sich das bald
ändert ich will aber noch was ganz
anderes was ganz essentielles loswerden
streit ist gold streit
ist die essenz von wissenschaft also
wissenschaft funktioniert nur durch
fortlaufende kritische überprüfung und
auseinandersetzung es ist auch kein
zufall dass eine doktorprüfung in der
wissenschaft als verteidigung bezeichnet
wird wenn man verteidigt seine arbeit
gegen experten die wiederum versuchen
die arbeit zu zerlegen und die schwächen
aufzudecken und auch wissenschaftliche
studien müssen verteidigt werden also
bevor eine studie in einem fachjournal
publiziert werden darf wird sind im
sogenannten peer review unterzogen
übersetzt der überprüfung review durch
kollegen pierce wo sich eben andere
wissenschaftler mit dem manuskript und
den daten kritisch auseinandersetzen
fehler oder ungenauigkeiten bemängeln
und überarbeitung und fordern in seinen
von chrome läuft der veröffentlichungs
prozess ein bisschen anders als am ende
gibt es immer noch das ganz normale peer
review aber weil das ganze normalerweise
recht lange dauert und wissenschaftliche
kenntnisse gerade recht dringend sind
werden viele studien auf sogenannten pre
print server veröffentlicht
so auch die studie von frost ist ihm da
kann man ja drauf schauen und man kann
dann auch open previews schreiben also
das öffentlich region das heißt streits
ak wissenschaftliche sachliche
auseinandersetzung ist kein drama das
ist wissenschaftliches tagesgeschäft und
übrigens wenn wir schon mal dabei sind
hendrik strick ist ja mit der heinsberg
studie was ähnliches passiert ist ja
dass ich professor stricks
wissenschaftskommunikation kritisiert
habe und auch wenn ich bei meiner
kommunikations kritik bleibe so gab es
in den medienberichten über die
forschung an sich auch unnötiges drama
rechenfehler mindert aussagekraft sogar
an einer studie selbst beteiligte
wissenschaftler räumt den rechenfehler
selbst ein beteiligter räumte den fehler
ein
juli willkommen in der wissenschaft an
jeden tag fehler eingeräumt ich weiß es
mag für manche politiker oder
journalisten ein meint bloß ein
aber auch hier wieder wissenschaftliches
tagesgeschäft nur die bild stellt sich
jetzt gedacht holt mal bier schlimmer
geht's immer die inhaltlichen reviews
der anderen wissenschaftler
hennes volle konsequenzen und dass die
kritik angenommen wurde ist brisant dass
die bild eine sachliche
wissenschaftliche auseinandersetzung als
essing darstellt zeigt im besten fall
davon dass da jemand da keine ahnung von
wissenschaft hat und im schlechtesten
fall ist das eine böse inszenierung das
alles finde ich sehr bedauerlich denn
solche artikel erschüttern das
grundvertrauen in die wissenschaft und
das obwohl diese streits genau das
gegenteil bewirken
sie stellen die verlässlichkeit von
wissenschaftlichen studien sicher okay
das war jetzt ein langer exkurs weg vom
roten faden machen wir mal einen großen
bogen zurück und ich habe auch schon die
perfekte überleitung fielen die deutsche
schulpolitik einer falschen studie zum
opfer da der bild redakteur diese frage
nicht selbst beantwortet übernehme ich
das gerne
nein unabhängig von der ganzen statistik
ist ostens studie keine schlüssel studie
in dieser schule und kita frage sondern
noch mal ein puzzleteil also schauen wir
doch lieber auf das große bild und
kommen zurück zu den fragen stecken sich
kinder seltener an und sind kinder
weniger anstrengend also ich kann hier
die zuversicht der stellungnahme nicht
teilen nachdem ich mir die
originalquellen angeschaut habe wir
haben auch schon wieder beim thema auch
über die interpretation von daten kann
man tat sich nicht sachlich streiten wir
haben hier nicht den luxus die bei der
ersten frage wo jetzt eine politikerin
sein kann
super dass ja alles safe das machen wir
jetzt so warum sprechen sich dann die
mediziner und hygieniker dann so
deutlich für eine öffnung aus man müsste
ja egal wo auch immer man hinschaut
natürlich auch gegenläufige effekte
sieht man müsste cluster finden kinder
übertragen
ja also zum beispiel auch auf die alb
und die findet man auch nicht und man
findet bis heute keine wirklichen beleg
dafür dass das gegenteil stimmt von dem
was hier beschrieben ist
bei influenza
wie zb bei der schweinegrippe schienen
schulschließungen eine besonders
wirksame bremse der epidemie zu sein
doch da waren kinder auch besonders
schwer betroffen und stecken sich
besonders oft an falco wird 19 ist das
anders und es fehlen bisher belege das
schul und kita schließungen hier eine
schlüssel maßnahme zur kontrolle der
epidemie sind die man nicht auch durch
andere maßnahmen ersetzen könnte und im
anbetracht der großen kolateralschäden
dieser schließungen ist es
nachvollziehbar wenn man sagt was auf
schul und kita schließungen sind nicht
die effizientesten bremser dieser
epidemie
lasst doch lieber anderen effizienteren
stellschrauben drehen und dann die
kinder und eltern wieder entlassen ich
selbst bin jetzt persönlich eher jemand
der vorsichtige öffnung noch lockerungen
aber ich finde das sind alles legitime
sichtweise noch ein paar wichtige praxis
stimmen fehlen ja noch das ist heinz
peter meidinger präsident des deutschen
lehrerverbandes und das ist jetzt reiner
zufall
schulleiter des robert koch gymnasiums
in niederbayern dem ziel jungen gelogen
haben bis zuletzt sind auch heute noch
der auffassung dass man mich so
einfacher über die mangelnde
infektiosität von von kindern sprechen
kommen gesehen alle unzufrieden damit
dass die kinder nicht in die schule
können das team nicht betreut werden das
ist eine gesellschaft riss kaum auf
haltbare situation aber das rechtfertigt
meines erachtens nicht dass wir jetzt
sozusagen leichtfertig in experimente
gehen
deswegen schlägt die stellungnahme auch
eine ordentliche wissenschaftliche
beobachtung und überprüfung dieser
öffnungen vor doch eher meidinger sieht
vor allem die praktische aspekte
kritisch zum beispiel schlägt die
stellungnahme ein an sich interessantes
konzept vor kleinstgruppen oder auch
maßnahmen wie abstand oder masken bei
den jüngeren kindern sei nicht notwendig
so lange man darauf achtet dass die
kinder und jugendlichen konstante
kontakte haben dass sich die gruppen
nicht missen doch meidinger sieht er vor
allem an den weiterführenden schulen
verschiedene hören allein schon im
lehrplan weil es normalerweise durch
mischungen gibt im sportunterricht im
reli unterricht bei verschiedenen
fremdsprachen aus den gang zu den
klassenräumen aus den gassen heimann in
der pause sollte vor dem bild
schulbereich und was überhaupt nicht
vermeiden lässt bereich der
schulbushaltestelle
das ist nicht wirklich also klappen
trennung konsequent noch zu spüren
manche sagen jetzt zumindest für die
weiterführenden schulen warum nutzt man
die zeit jetzt nicht um das
homeschooling und den digital unterricht
auszubauen wäre das nicht die bessere
lösung es gibt nicht die gesamten die
zentralschule dass es hat unsere schule
festgestellt und die 40 gehört von den
850 oder was erreichen wir nicht weil
sie zu hause kein gerät haben die geräte
haben wir haben der schule dann die
landesregierung gestellt in berlin die
tauben koch gymnasium das orga koch
gemeinsam in berlin des eigentlichen
brennpunkt gymnasium absolut
verdienstvolle schule sehen sie den
schülern
auch zum abitur gebracht hat aber das
glaube ich ein stricher geräten nicht
reichen
so oder so wird klar selbst wenn man
sich dazu entschließen würde dieser
stellungnahme zu folgen würde das nicht
bedeuten dass jetzt plötzlich wieder
alle einrichtungen öffnen weil die
grundvoraussetzungen für die öffnung
wahrscheinlich bei den meisten
einrichtungen noch nicht gegeben sind
denn die stellungnahme sagt ihr eben
nicht bitte öffnet einfach sondern sie
sagt wir müssen dringend öffnen aber
folgende sachen müssen gegeben sein es
darf keine durchmischung der gruppen
geben die gene maßnahmen müssen alle
geklärt sein wir müssen wir testen den
business wissenschaftlich begleiten usw
allem auch für unsere daten
zusammenfassen braucht man immer die
realität vor ort wir brauchen die eltern
mit dem boot wir brauchen die
schulleitungen im boot und deswegen ist
das schon ein präsent ihr un prozess den
wir ja auch man stützt
wir sagen ja nicht macht das jetzt
bedarf an sondern ihr schaffen
die argumentation die schulen und kitas
haben im märz und im april schon viel
zeit verloren weil aus der politik im
anno kam ja wir warten jetzt mal ab und
dann schauen wir mal aber jetzt wissen
wir ja dass coroner noch lange ein
problem bleiben wird deswegen zum
schluss noch ein kurzes update zu
unserer aktuellen epidemiologischen lage
viele kroner schutzmaßnahmen wurden
gelockert andere kamen hinzu und da
scheint richtig gut aufzugehen denn
obwohl wir in deutschland spürbar mehr
freiheiten genießen als letzten monat
sind die infektionszahlen gesunken
ich war vor ein paar wochen wirklich
besorgt weil ich damit gerechnet hatte
schon das mit den lockerungen die
infektionszahlen wieder hoch gehen aber
zum glück hatte ich da unrecht ein
weiterer grund für die niedrigen
fallzahlen mag ein gewisser sommer
effekt sein wie wir in unserem quarks co
in fünf minuten am dienstag erklärt
haben und wir wissen inzwischen mehr
über den sogenannten dispersions faktor
von kommune und es sieht momentan alles
danach aus dass die meisten menschen
also die meisten infizierten nur wenige
oder vielleicht sogar niemanden
anstecken während wenige infizierte ganz
viele anstecken also
das stichwort super spacer aber dazu
müsste man auch ein extra video machen
was aber gleich das virus ist immer noch
dasselbe also ist jetzt nicht bissig
harmloser geworden das sieht man auch
mit einem blick ins ausland zum beispiel
in die usa oder nach brasilien die haben
da ja dasselbe virus wie wir ziemlich
normal sein wenn wir zu dem alltag
zurückkehren den wir vor sämtlichen
maßnahmen hatten
dann wird auch die epidemie wieder so
laufen wie vor den maßnahmen
stellungnahme der mediziner ist wie sie
selbst sagen ein guter anfang und jetzt
muss schnell weiter geplant werden aber
wir brauchen klar ihr könnt ich einfach
planlos öffnen
wer von euch ist schüler und wer von
euch arbeitet an einer kita oder schule
schreibt doch mal in die kommentare
was zu diesem schul und kita thema in
der öffentlichkeit zu wenig diskutiert
wird ansonsten ich war bei der carolin
kebekus show hier ist der sketch schaut
mal vorbei und lob mich bitte dafür dass
ich nicht gelacht habe und ich war beim
song kindern eines der besten interview
formate ever schaut auch da gerne vorbei
wir sehen uns in zwei wochen und bis
dahin bleibt sicher